I
[Music]
why the godlike heaven bread Turkish
wise cog on I have mounted my throne
here from the beginning to the end of my
words first and foremost ye my younger
brothers my brothers and my sisters sons
and my young princes and then all ye my
kindred and my people he shut up it begs
on the right he talked hands and work
pegs on the left
o twos begs and people of the toe coos
Oh curses hearken well to these my words
give close heed to them
[Music]
towards the east towards the sun's
rising towards the south towards the
mid-day towards the west towards the
sun's setting towards the north towards
the midnight LED all peoples within this
circle listen to me
so far around have i disposed all the
peoples so long as the turkish car GaN
rules in the forests of mount
Otakon without the wickedness of today
the kingdom suffers no ill to the east I
have made campaigns as far as the
shantung plane and almost reached the
sea to the south I have made campaigns
as far as toku Saracen and almost
reached Tibet to the West I have made
campaigns beyond the yen shoes as far as
Tamiya capping to the North I have made
campaigns as far as the Land of the Year
bear coos to all these lands have I led
the Turks the Forest of Mount Otto Kahn
has no foreign Overlord the Forest of
Mount Otto Kahn is the place where from
the kingdom is held together while I
have ruled here I have become reconciled
with the Chinese people the Chinese
people who give in abundance gold silver
millet and silk have always used
ingratiating words hand have at their
disposal innovating riches while in
snaring them with their ingratiating
talk and innovating riches they have
drawn the fard welling people's nearer
to themselves but after setting down
near them these have come to see their
cunning the good and shrewd man the good
and stout man however they have not
shaken and even if a man have fallen
away from us they have not succeeded in
leading astray the sober ones within his
kindred or his people but by letting
yourselves be snared by
ingratiating talk and enervating riches
many of you Turkish folk have gone to
destruction when some among you Turkish
folks said I will settle in the south
but not in the forest of mount true guy
but in the plane then the wicked man
encouraged this party among you Turkish
folk in this wise when they are far away
they give bad gifts when they are near
they give good gifts
thus did they urge them on the foolish
persons were taken by these words and
went down to their neighborhood whereby
many among you have come to destruction
if thou then go forth to that land o
Turkish nation that will come to
destruction but if they'll stay in the
land of Batu Khan and send out caravans
that will never suffer any need if thou
stay on in the mountain forests of a
toucan thou shalt ever hold an
everlasting Kingdom o Turkish nation and
thou shalt be full fed when now are
hungry thou dost not remember what
fullness is but once thou art full fed
thou has no thought of what hunger is
without giving heed to the words of your
car Gong of him who thanks to those or
like-mind
among you has set you on your feet ye
have wandered forth from place to place
and he have all their languished and
suffered need those among you that have
stayed behind there all have had to go
on from place to place to life or death
under the will of heaven and for that it
was my high calling
I became qug on after having become car
GaN I gathered together the whole
luckless people the poor people I have
made rich the people small in numbers I
have made a numerous one or is there
perhaps any untruth in these my words
turkish pegs and people's hearken unto
this how thou o turkish people has
preserved the kingdom through being
obedient i have here written down how
thou has been divided up when thou was
faithless I have here set forth all that
I had to say to you I have written down
on this everlasting stone having obeyed
this ye Turkish people's and begs now
living he begs that up to now have been
obedient to a throne could you indeed
wish to be found wanting
I have had the memorial stone hewn from
the Chinese emperor I have had artists
to come and have set them to work my
request has not been refused
they have sent the Chinese Emperor's
court painters I have bidden them set up
a separate hall and inside and out I
have had them to make various remarkable
paintings I have had the stone hewn that
which lay in my heart to utter I have
had written understand to see this all
as far as the sons and subjects of the
ten arrows I have had the memorial stone
hewn for those of you who might have
been withdrawing into winter camp or
from barren places striving towards
grazing ground I have had this memorial
stone hewn in a barren place and have
written this when you see it then know
so much this stone I have he that has
written this inscription is his sister's
son yo leaked egg in